a dreux en eure et loir les règlements
de compte que redouté la police après la
fusillade qui a eu lieu samedi ne se
sont bien heureusement pas produit pour
tenter de comprendre ce qui a pu pousser
les cinq jeunes agresseurs a tiré sur un
groupe de maghrébins
michèle fines et michel giannoulas taux
se sont rencontrés le père de deux de
ses agresseurs
son explication l'alcool et la bêtise
sont fait agresser par un gamin comme ça
que ça commençait sont fait agresser par
un gamin par les histoires de 50 francs
ils ont voulu acheter un petit rue
gamble à l'arraché porte-monnaie il
s'est sauvé avec et c'est vrai que pour
tourner et son parti et sans revenus et
en tirer ce que les agresseurs venaient
acheter hier dans le quartier de la
croix thiézac c'était de la drogue
quelques grammes de haschisch lorsque
les choses ont mal tourné ils sont
partis puis ils sont revenus avec des
fusils il voulait se venger
ils étaient libres de grosses
installations emilia rockies avaient
certainement restée dans la voiture des
agresseurs jean paul huber avait deux
fils l'aîné ses fans a été abattu par le
policier sur lequel il venait de tirer
fabrice a été arrêté en croire leur père
il ne s'agit pas d'un acte aura six rien
du tout
ils sont comme leur pays n'ont jamais
voté nico
un truc de boisson c'est tout c'est une
connerie virades 8 dt
ça ressemble à rien ou en plus c'est
trop tard et plus rien à 57 foot us
c'est tout
je suis bien à goûter l'eau mais aussi
pour tout le monde parmi les agresseurs
il y avait deux mineurs ce soir ils
seront mises en examen pour homicide
volontaire